pressure is growing on prime minister
nicole pachinyan
with the president on saturday refusing
to sign his letter dismissing the head
of the armed forces
saying it was unconstitutional for the
opposition
it's a sign things are going their way
[Music]
let us salute the decision of the
president our people are standing with
the army
like the army is standing with the
people and now the president of the
republic stands with the army
the opposition accuses nicole of
treachery
over his handling of the war over
nagorno-karabakh
the peace deal he signed in november
ceded huge territory to azerbaijan
at the cost of over three and a half
thousand armenian lives
and the war isn't the only reason why
many armenians have lost
faith in nikol pashinyan promises he
made
when he came to power three years ago
remain unfulfilled
that was his expectation that only his
statements
will allow to arrest all corruptioners
or to make judges honest and
professional
but no practical efforts were done for
that
people so that is nobody is
really punished for misdoings uh
they they lose their optimist and trust
in
possibility of uh
progress of the country with pashanyan
as a leader
the street protests demanding mr
passionians resignation
have been bolstered by support from the
army generals
the church and now the president of the
republic
the prime minister's response on
saturday evening
was to return the decree dismissing the
head of the armed services
back to the president asking him again
to sign the document
or take the matter to the constitutional
court
robin forrester walker al jazeera
yerevan